ni el gobierno de Daniel Ortega ni los
cableoperadores nicaragüenses se han
pronunciado sobre Por qué tomaron la
decisión de sacar del aire la señal de
CNN en español sin embargo se desprenden
varias hipótesis una de ellas por
supuesto es la Cruzada de censura que
está llevando a cabo el gobierno de
Daniel Ortega en contra de los medios de
comunicación independientes y teniendo
en cuenta que CNN en español es una de
las cadenas más populares dentro de los
nicaragüenses es posible que esta
decisión haya sido tomada sobre todo
porque CNN en español habla de la
realidad nicaragüense con invitados
internacionales muchos de ellos
nicaragüenses en el exilio quienes
califican al gobierno de Ortega de
Dictadura otra de las hipótesis de
expertos de medios de comunicación está
relacionada con las actuales alianzas
que está llevando a cabo el gobierno de
Daniel Ortega con medios de comunicación
extranjeros como el grupo de medios de
China y las cadenas rusas sputnik y RT
en aras de que la información
brindar a los nicaragüenses estén
concordancia con las políticas de
izquierda con las políticas de Ortega y
para tal menester CNN en español sería
una especie de invitado no deseado a la
fiesta de la información en Nicaragua Lo
cierto es que estén en español se
convierte en la primera cadena
internacional de noticias en ser cerrada
en ser apagada su señal en Nicaragua y
abre la posibilidad para que otras
cadenas internacionales que se emiten en
Nicaragua también serán cerradas como
bbc de Londres lados chebel y nosotros
France 24